[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Thanks,
everyone, for coming today.
So first thing I
wanted to do is just
review where we are, as usual,
in terms of the calendar.
So we did the first part of
contracts and mechanism design
as kind of an
introduction last time.
And now we're going to
do the second, which
is very explicit about
another application
beyond medieval villages.
And we'll definitely have
real, live data and so on.
And then by Thursday, we will
get into general Equilibrium,
again, Walraisian
worlds, and begin
to look at trade applications
both in emerging markets
and then later in the US.
I'll say a little bit
about the reading list,
especially since
you might miss this.
The paper application that
we're going to feature today
is this paper with my
coauthors on five villages.
And we're going to both
stress the application using
the tools you've already
learned in a different context
but also some of the techniques.
Remember, the class
is trying to balance
both learning tools and
how to use them as well
as the economics so please don't
miss this Karaivanov starred
article, including moral
hazard programs with lotteries
because I will say a lot
about those techniques today
but not enough.
So there's two starred articles.
Again, I have earmarked
a few of these
from what we did last time.
For mechanism design,
we did a single period.
We worked through the
so-called revelation principle.
And finally, we got to
a two-period problem.
And the review question
is written here
is, now maintaining
the lotteries,
write down the programming
problem for the two
periods, dates one and two.
I'm not asking you to
literally write it down.
But could someone
volunteer to tell me
about the truth-telling
constraints
at the final date two, in
words, what they look like?
And then also in words, what the
true telling constraint of date
one looks like.
AUDIENCE: I remember the
truth-telling constraint
at the final entry is that
no matter what you already
announce at the date 1, based
on the [INAUDIBLE] how would you
announce at the date
1, you want to choose--
The truth-telling bring
you the maximized utility.
[INAUDIBLE] function is like
the utility at the date two
is the [INAUDIBLE] and
which modify the probability
function.
The probability
function was depending
on what you announce
in the [INAUDIBLE] one.
And then the whole
function would be bigger
than any announcement
at the [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, and
what about at date one?
AUDIENCE: The date one
is that you do not only
care about what you
will get at this moment.
But you also care
about the future.
I mean, that for date one,
the maximize the utility.
Not maximize, the
you're telling the truth
that bring you
the utility, which
is larger than any date 1.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, and what
is it assuming about date two,
even though it's a
date one constraint?
AUDIENCE: Assuming about
the date two is that it--
The date two not
care about what--
Yeah.
They do not care.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
you're very close.
So the point of working
backwards, at date two,
we get the truth-telling
constraint.
So the utility is greater
for telling the truth
and announcing something
counterfactual.
That's now imposed as part of
the solution as a constraint.
So working back to
date one, it assumes
truth telling at date two.
So we only have to worry about
whether to be truthful at date
one or lie at date one.
Because whatever they do,
truth or lie at date one,
they will tell the
truth that date two.
So related to all of
this is the message,
the announcement of date one.
You said something
not quite right.
But I may have heard it wrong.
There's a probability
transition function
that has to do with a
probability of states
at date two, conditioned
on dates at state one.
And that never changes.
That's just part
of the environment.
What changes, until the
one that you mentioned,
is the message at date one,
depending on whether or not the
total the truth.
So the very last part
of this review question
asks to describe
the way in which
past history matters or
contemporary outcomes.
AUDIENCE: So the key is
that the history matters,
the probability function, right?
Because if you're telling the--
Whatever you tell at
the date one, that
will decide the probability
because the probability was
conditioning on what are you are
telling, what do you announce.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
So I don't think I
have that lecture open anymore.
We'd have to go
back and look at it.
No, it's buried
back deeper in them.
Go back and look at
the Markov Process.
The probability P of theta
2, condition on theta 1,
there's never--
That part never changes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
I'm mixing it.
I should say the lottery.
I always say the probability.
Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK,
OK, yeah, lottery.
Yeah, they're both
probabilities.
I understand.
OK, good.
Thank you.
That's perfect.
OK, and then relatedly, there's
this question right afterwards,
what does the solution to that
two-period problem look like?
Is it full insurance?
Is it borrowing and lending?
And if it's not either, one
what is the logic of why
we know it can't be either?
So let me take--
AUDIENCE: Let me
take a stab at this.
But yeah, so I
remember that we said
that the full insurance
wasn't optimal
because if you had
full insurance, then
it wouldn't be truth-telling.
And so you would
never be able to reach
that optimal equilibrium there.
For the borrowing and
lending, I remember
we had some kind
of argument where
we said that the incentive
constraints won't bind.
And so because
those didn't bind,
it's equivalent to just
not having the incentive
constraints at all.
Which means you might as well
just do full risk sharing.
But we already showed
that we could do that.
But I don't think I quite recall
why the incentive constraints
don't bind in the first place.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
it's a perfect answer.
Thank you.
And to answer your question,
the presumption is somehow,
if your income is low,
you want to borrow.
And you strictly
prefer that to lending.
So that strict preference
is a strict inequality
in the constraint and
hence, not binding.
And likewise, if
your income is high,
you strictly prefer to lend
rather than borrow, OK?
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
Thanks.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
Your answer was really good.
Thank you.
OK, so let's go to maybe
one more thing here.
I did feel that I
was rushing a bit
toward the end of the lecture.
So I'm happy to take
questions rather
than going through these.
Let's try a couple of them to
get the conversation going.
I drew a distinction
between encryption, hashing,
and cryptographic puzzles.
Does anyone remember?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think I know this one.
So encryption is where you have
some specific key secret key
shared between two parties.
And then you can use that
key to encrypt a message
and then decrypt it
at the other end.
Hashing is some function that
it changes pretty randomly,
depending on the input.
So it's distorts things that
encapsulates the whole message.
And if you change
a message, it's
very hard to change a message
to keep the same hash.
A cryptographic
puzzle, I think, it's
something that is hard to do.
And it's known to
be hard in some way.
And I think
homomorphic encryption,
I think that's the one where
you have basically what
amounts to a linear function.
So you just encrypt something.
Add together all the
encrypted things,
and then you can
decrypt the sum.
And then you can get the
correct decrypted sum
without having to know any
of the individual components,
or something like that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Very good.
Excellent.
Just a couple words of comment.
The encryption part, it's
private and public keys.
And the private keys
are never shared.
It's the public key that's
shared between the parties.
AUDIENCE: I just described
symmetric encryption.
Yeah, it's also
private, public keys.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, you
have the background for this.
OK, excellent.
Yeah, and hashing
is what you said.
It's kind of a one-way function.
You know what goes in.
But you cannot
interpret what goes out.
And the puzzles are fine.
And homomorphic
encryption is fine.
So thank you, that's great.
Sounds like you might have known
the answers to these things
before the class.
But I mean, from other
work that you're doing.
But that's fine.
Let's see, one last thing.
Consensus Protocol.
Is a consensus
protocol necessarily
incentive compatible?
So this is like begging
for a discussion of how
computer science use the
word trust and economics use
the word trust.
And again, I'm just
taking volunteers today.
So again, lots of
information on those
slides just kind of
appeared on one slide
and I didn't belabor it.
The basic idea in
computer science
is that most nodes
are trustworthy.
They're going to
follow the protocol.
But a handful of nodes or
actors are either faulty,
in the sense of the
computer doesn't work well,
or nefarious in the sense
that they're determined
to undercut the system.
So the basic premise is, most
nodes are honest in the sense
that they're going to
follow the algorithm.
In economics, it's
a dismal science.
We don't trust anybody.
So everyone, on the other
hand, can be given incentives.
So we assume maximizing utility
or profit-maximizing behavior.
And then we load
things up in a way
that even though there are
secrets, like preference shocks
or unobserved states
and so on, the actors
have an incentive to reveal
what those states are.
So the message is, as
in mechanism design
that we did earlier
in the lecture,
are part of the contract.
And they're going
to be sent honestly.
But it's due to the
incentive constraints.
And without the
incentive constraints,
we kind of assume
everyone's going to cheat.
So it is kind of a
philosophical difference.
Anyway, that's
why, in the lecture
I put the discussion of
bitcoin and other algorithms
in the context of mechanism
design to draw this contrast.
OK, so that's the review sheet.
And let's get to
don't lecture here.
OK, so today part two,
more on contracts.
So the application is going
to be financial markets.
And we're going to try to figure
out what kind of contracts
a small business would
write with a lender.
In particular, what the
underlying obstacles to trade
are.
We're going to want to identify,
from data using the theory,
what those obstacles are
that limit the ability to go
into business or
limit the ability
to finance the business once
you're already in business.
So that's the
economics part of it.
The technique part
of it is, we're
going to do a structural
estimation of the model.
But we will also look at some
reduced form techniques that
are data summaries
that are consistent
with the structural model.
Essentially, we use
reduced-form techniques
to identify stylized
facts different
across different regions.
And then we use
the theory to try
to make sense of
what we're seeing.
It's kind of an
experimental laboratory.
And there are going to be
two sources of constraints.
So one is for short, a
collateral constraint.
Agents can borrow, but
potentially not much.
In order to borrow, they
have to post collateral
so that the amount
they can borrow
is limited by their wealth.
That means low-wealth households
may not borrow very much.
And it may not make sense
to go into a business at all
because they can only operate
at a very small scale.
Or if they do go into
business, because it's the best
alternative
notwithstanding, they
are not investing very much
because of that collateral
constraint.
Now when there's a collateral
constraint that's binding,
the borrowing is a
proportion of wealth.
So if you're thinking about
going across different firms
in the cross section,
as net worth increases,
borrowing would increase, again,
for constrained entrepreneurs.
On the other hand, it
doesn't necessarily
mean that with this collateral
constraint everyone's
going to be borrowing.
They may have enough wealth
to entirely self-finance.
Or the borrowing constraint
isn't binding in the sense
that they don't go
up to the limit.
They have some wealth.
They borrow
additional resources.
But they could have borrowed
more and they don't do it.
On the other hand, a different
constraint is a moral hazard.
Now moral hazard means that,
it's a funny terminology.
It's like you buy an
insurance policy that's
supposed to pay off if
your house burns down.
But because you're
insured, then you
don't pay attention and take
the appropriate precautionary
measures.
So the house is
likely to burn down.
For some reason, in
the insurance industry,
this is referred
to as moral hazard
as if it were, quote, "immoral."
But again, from
our dismal science,
economics point of view.
It's not immoral, per se.
It's just that it didn't
have the right incentives.
And in this moral hazard world,
effort, diligence, taking care
is not observed.
So the only way the insurance
company or the lender
can get the money back is when
there's not an adverse event
or the firm is successful
in making profit.
Now that means that
poor borrowers who
owe a lot of money
don't have an incentive
to work very hard at being
diligent because they're going
to pay the bulk of
their returns back
if they're successful
to the bank
or to the insurance company.
So they don't take care.
And the probability
of failure is high.
It's a constraint.
Because the
probability of failure
could be high, especially
for low-wealth agents,
the banks, in order to
break even on those loans,
have to charge high
interest rates.
And in fact, the rate
could be so high,
it would be high
enough for the lender
to break even but
the borrower is
no longer interested because
it's just too high of a rate.
And likewise, high
rates, they may not
want to borrow very much, even
if they do go into business.
Another difference with
the collateral constraint
is in the moral hazard world,
the incentive constraint
is always binding.
That's a version of what
we were just discussing,
full insurance is never optimal
because under full insurance,
you exert minimal effort.
So you don't offer
full insurance.
But likewise, then
effort it is lower
than it would have been in
a full information world.
So the incentive constraint, to
be diligent, is always binding.
And the way out of that
problem, if in a cross section,
entrepreneurs have more and
more wealth comparing one
to the other, then they
can self-finance more.
And the more you self-finance,
the less you have to pay back.
So in this case, as wealth
goes up, borrowing goes down.
That's exactly the
opposite from what
we got in the limited
liability case
for constrained entrepreneurs.
When wealth went up,
borrowing went up.
So I alluded to these
reduced-form statistics.
We will see again at some
point a summary of the data
that, depending on the
region that they're in,
we will see either this one
result in the cross section
or the other one.
And the goal then is to
take the full-blown model
and do structural
estimates to determine
which constrain is binding.
It could be one.
It could be the other.
Actually, technically,
it could be both.
And I'm going to show you that
once we review the tools we
already have, pending on
the appropriate constraints,
it's actually easy to test
one versus the other versus
multiple.
It's relatively easy to do.
But we are learning some
of those new tools today.
That's half of the
point of the lecture.
So I've made reference twice
to differences across regions.
I think I may have shown
you this picture before.
But I'm not sure.
We certainly looked
at the Thai data.
We looked at the monthly data
when we did risk and return
in village Thailand, which
was the second application
of the risk-sharing sections.
So anyway, Bangkok's over here.
This is central region.
These yellow provinces were
ones that I had surveyed
in annual data since 1997.
And over here in the East, but
they call it the Northeast,
we have two other provinces.
These are predominantly
rural, agricultural.
The ones near Bangkok are
much more industrialized.
And here's a map of
Sisaket, just to show you
where the data are coming from.
We've got a lot
of little villages
here, these little dots, as well
as parts of the road network.
And then the colored
circles correspond to,
if they're purple,
these clusters
are where we gather the
annual data that we're
going to be using today.
In the previous lectures, Risk
and Return in Village Thailand,
we were using the monthly data.
And those are stars.
And if you look
really closely, you'll
eventually find a cluster
with the stars that
correspond to the monthly data.
The annual data are
spread out much more.
Those stars are up here.
They're just not visible.
I know these provinces
like the back of my hand
because I've been
there so often.
OK, so again, Thai
data, 1997 onwards,
almost 3,000 households.
They're running
their businesses.
As you know, livestock,
fish, shrimp, farm,
and small business like vendors.
And we have those two
regions of the country.
The cool thing is
that in 1997, we
had the foresight
to ask about some
of the things that had happened
in the last five years.
So we have their
wealth retrospectively,
what it was five
years ago before 1997,
and also what kind of occupation
they were engaged in five years
before 1997.
So that those are two of
the key variables, namely,
how much wealth did
you have in 1992?
And what business
were you in 1992?
And then, did you change
your occupation, say,
going from being a wage
earner to going into business
over those five year periods?
And again, we're going to
find the bottom line is
the data on wealth and
occupation transitions
as well as the
cross-sectional data is going
to favor moral hazard as being
the constraint in the wealthier
central region.
And in the Northeast, it's going
to be that limited liability,
although frequently,
both limited liability
and moral hazard in combination.
So hopefully, you're
wondering how on Earth we
could ever figure this all out.
Here, by the way, is the
picture of increasing wealth
and increasing
probability of making
a transition into business.
So this line here is upward
sloping, the higher the wealth,
the higher the transition.
But this could, in theory,
be a very steep profile
or a very flat one.
So part of it is estimating the
profile suggested by the theory
and then comparing it
to the actual data.
Here's the model.
So agents, all these ingredients
should be very familiar by now.
You've seen them at least
twice and maybe more.
Households that could run a firm
or could just be a wage earner
cares about the utility
of consumption and effort.
So the consumption part
is constant relative risk
aversion.
And the degree of risk aversion
is gamma when gamma is zero.
This thing is linear.
That's risk neutral so
not risk averse at all.
As gamma gets higher
and higher, you
have more and more curvature.
And then entering
inseparably, linearly
is this utility of effort,
Z being effort, taking care,
due diligence, how
hard you're working,
again, raised to a power like
constant relative risk aversion
to a different degree.
Gamma 2, rather than
gamma 1 and kappa,
reflects the utility trade-off
between consumption and effort.
So not to say you
need to memorize this.
But we can pay attention
to the parameters.
We got three of them here,
gamma 1, gamma 2, and kappa.
So we would like
to estimate those.
And we will start
looking at the model
when gamma 1 is zero,
hence, risk neutral,
and then let them be
risk averse and estimate
the model generally.
The estimation will
use linear programming.
You've seen this trade-off
between consumption and effort.
When we did the lecture on
utility and preferences,
there was a slide
at the very end
that had the agent choosing
between work and wheat
as an output.
And we actually did that
in the right-hand side
with respect to
consumption and leisure
or the left-hand
side with respect
to consumption and effort.
So this is a parametric version
of those same preferences.
More on the model, households
differ with respect
to initial wealth.
As I said, call
that A for assets.
They differ with respect
to talent, theta.
Some people are better
things than other people
like running a business.
And S as is the level of
schooling, formal education.
All are observed by the
agents and even by the banks.
That's a bit of a stretch.
But we are imagining
the bank can see wealth
and talent and education.
We however, only see what
we have in the data, which
is wealth and schooling.
We do not see
talent as modelers.
But we can make some
assumption about it, namely,
it's log linear.
Talent log theta is log linear
in assets and schooling.
And we assume that
error term is normally
distributed with a mean
0 and variance of 1.
Why are we doing this?
Well, we want to
distinguish the constraint.
But the worry is that
talented people in the past
have been more successful
and hence, already
have higher assets.
We want to be able to
distinguish the set part, which
is wealth, which plays a role
in the financing constraints,
versus talent, which is
productivity, which is entry
in the production function.
If we didn't allow talent
to depend on wealth,
then we could incorrectly infer
that financing constraints are
playing a role because
higher wealth allows
people to do better.
But actually, it could
be playing a role
through this third
variable, namely
talent, that higher wealth
means higher talent,
reflects higher talent.
And it's actually
higher talent that
is the reason some people
are in business and operating
at a higher scale.
So this is kind
of a shorthand way
to allow things to be correlated
and not incorrectly infer
something about causality.
Other parts of the model,
q is output, profits.
It's a function of effort
and capital if you're a firm.
Or wage-earners, if
you're not a firm,
this output can take on
two values for simplicity,
namely success and failure.
So when they're successful in
the project, the value of q
is theta.
So more talented entrepreneurs
have higher output conditioned
on being successful.
And the other simplification
is the failure, which
means they have zero output.
And if you have zero
output, then you're
not going to repay a loan.
And there's no output with
which to repay the loan.
So this whole branch of q
equals 0 becomes simplistic.
Anyway, yeah, two extremes
here, three really.
Talent only enters
through success.
There's only two values
of profitability, success
or failure.
And failure corresponds
with zero output.
So let's look then at the
probability of success.
The probability of q is
equal to theta, the high one,
conditioned on effort and
the level of capitalization
of the firm.
And that's essentially in the
numerator like a Cobb-Douglass
function.
K is capital.
z is effort to the power
is alpha and 1 minus alpha,
a function you've seen before.
Now why is it being
divided by something?
Well, this whole thing is
supposed to be a probability.
Probability of success is
a number between 0 and 1.
So if k and z were 0,
the numerator is 0.
0 divided by 1 is 0.
So that's the left endpoint.
And likewise, if k and z are
getting really, really big
and there's no natural
bound here yet,
then this numerator
is getting really big.
But so is the same term
in the denominator.
So this whole term is going
to 1 because the numerator
and denominator are
getting very, very similar.
So this P function is a
probability between 0 and 1,
no matter what k and z
are put into the firm.
Output is always
going to be observed
in the models that follow.
The issue is going to be whether
this effort z is observed
or not and whether k is
restricted by the collateral
constraint.
And I will show you
that in a minute.
And finally, the other branch,
not to lose sight of it,
they could choose
not to be a firm,
in which case k is equal to 0.
And when k is equal to 0,
the firm is not capitalized.
And effectively, the
household is a wage earner.
So earnings in the
wage sector are also
stochastic and probabilistic.
You can work hard to find a job.
That doesn't mean
you will find one.
The higher effort you
devote toward finding a job,
the higher would
be the probability
of getting the wage.
And again, this is
bounded between 0 and 1.
Now if you are a firm,
you may or may not borrow.
But if you borrow, there's
going to be an interest rate
schedule that determines
how much you pay back.
And that interest rate
schedule is a function of two
of the things the
lending firm observes,
the wealth of the household
and the household's talent.
And this schedule
is going to be such
that the banks, although
maximizing profits,
can at best break even.
And I'll show you that
constraint in a minute.
But I already alluded to it in
the sense of moral hazard being
a problem because
repayment going down
and banks having to raise
interest rates to cover
what otherwise would be losses.
They have to get enough
from the successful firms
to cover the fact that the
unsuccessful ones are not
paying off the loans.
When you're a worker
or a firm that is not
using all their
resources to borrow,
you have some
residual assets left.
They put it in the bank.
And they earn the
riskless rate of return.
So in some respects, there's
both borrowing and saving
going on here, depending on
what occupation you choose
and your underlying
characteristics.
So how are we going
to solve this problem?
We're going to solve for
a constrained optimum.
We are going to write
down a quote, unquote
"planner's problem," which I
sometimes refer to the math
problem, which is maximizing
lambda weighted sums
of utilities subject to
resource, truth-telling,
and liability constraints.
Now to restate that,
we're going to maximize
the utility, a weighted sum
of the utility of borrowers
and the utility of the banks.
The banks, however,
could make profits.
So we're just distinguishing,
in their case,
profits as a version of utility.
The second thing is, and I
didn't reload this picture,
if you go back to
the lecture where
we introduced the notion
of Pareto optimality.
We had the so-called
Pareto frontier.
And we decided the
points on the frontier
would be Pareto optimal.
And you could
achieve those points
by maximizing a particular
lambda-weighted sum
of utilities, or in this case,
a particular lambda-weighted sum
of profits and utility
of the borrower.
But there is another
way to do it,
which is to maximize the
utility of the borrower,
subject to a fixed
profit level of the bank.
Its equivalent, normally,
with these concave frontiers.
Then the next step is, OK,
there are many, many banks.
And they're competing.
If one representative bank were
to make a profit with respect
to the borrowing
customers, another bank
could step in and
undercut the first one
and do slightly better.
So this competitive
process is going
to drive the profits
of the bank down to 0.
So we're going to be looking
at particular Pareto optimum
where the utilities
of the borrowers
are maximized, subject to
a zero profit constraint
on the part of the lenders.
There are other optima we're
not going to look at today.
Although, it's going to be
clear from the equations how we
could have done
it more generally.
So this is the utility
of the borrower.
There are three
possible branches.
This is, again, the
risk-neutral borrower.
To get warmed up, if k
is 0, which is a choice.
But if the solution
is k equal to 0,
then, in fact, the household
is a wage-earner, not
a firm, deciding
on effort, which
determines the probability
of getting the wage,
although it comes at a
disutility cost of working.
And they put all their
wealth in the bank.
So that risk free rate
of interest times assets
is something they get at
the end of the period,
the savings account.
The second branch is
they do go into business
and there's capitalization
is positive,
but it's less than their
assets, so they can basically
take what's left, assets
minus capitalization,
and put it in the bank.
So these guys also get
a return on savings.
But part of their
wealth, the k part,
is stuck into the
production function.
So the return on that comes
from the possibility of profits.
And you still have
this trade-off
of probability of success
versus the disutility of effort.
And then the final
branch here is,
these guys have a k, which
is relatively large relative
to their assets.
So they got to borrow.
And this sign here
is a bit confusing.
But if k is greater than
a then a is less than k.
So this term is negative.
So naturally, they're
quote, "negative"
paying off the principal and
the interest on the loan.
And they only pay it off
if they're successful.
So again, this modified
Cobb-Douglas probability
expression is entering
in there as it does
for the probability of success.
So those are the three branches.
This is the
break-even constraint
of the bank, which as I've
said in words a couple of times
already, this is
the risk-free rate.
So a bank has basically got
to get funds from somewhere,
from depositors, actually.
And they've got to
break even because
of all that competition.
So they may get a higher return,
depending on the borrower's
wealth and talent.
But they only get that back when
that borrower is successful.
So this is the expected
return given the interest rate
schedule.
And that is driven down
to the risk-free rate.
So we have this 0
profit constraint
to impose as part
of the solution.
So again, to repeat
myself, instead
of maximizing a lambda-weighted
sum of utilities,
we're going to maximize
the utility of the borrower
subject to a particular
lambda for the bank,
a lambda, which is associated
with making zero profits.
And we just impose the
zero-profit constraint
from the get go.
It's also kind of
interesting in terms
of where we are in the
class because when we first
introduced utility
maximization, we
had these partial equilibrium
exercises in which prices
and so on were taken as given,
although we varied them to see
what the household will do.
Likewise, when we did the
firm, we had input prices as
taken as given.
And we did some experiments.
And here, likewise,
we're in quote, unquote
"partial equilibrium"
in the sense
that wage and the interest
rate are given to us.
We're not trying
to explain them.
They're going to be
part of the data.
On the other hand, we're
definitely doing a contracting
a problem here.
And to do it, we have to draw
on those tools about Pareto
optimality and so on
and how to determine
Pareto optimal outcomes
via programming problems.
So we kind of are drawing on to
different segments of the class
that we've covered already
in this application.
So let's talk about
limited liability.
So limited liability,
let's just jump down here.
It's easier here.
k, that they can use the
capitalization of the firm,
is bounded above
by their assets.
Actually, it's lambda, some
proportionality times assets.
So this is referred to as
a borrowing constraint.
Now lambda could
be greater than 1.
They may be able to borrow
more than their wealth.
But it is limited.
There's a little bit
of a derivation here.
I was thinking about
it this morning.
It's not really all
that compelling.
You can derive this
constraint by saying
there's a maximum amount
they can invest in the firm.
Then you write down the
equation for borrowing,
which is the difference
between capital and assets.
And then substitute in that
maximum amount for capital
and derive this equation.
This now has a on both
sides of the equation, which
you could drop.
And you get the
equation 6 as a result.
But I'm perfectly happy if
you wanted to start with 6.
The capital is bounded from
above due to a collateral
constraint related to wealth.
That's the limited
liability version.
Here's the moral hazard version.
In this case, the bank does
not see the borrower's effort.
So whatever the contract is
in terms of that repayment
schedule, and whatever the
level of capitalization that
the borrower can manage, the
choice of how much to work is
done by the borrower alone
and cannot be dictated.
And it's going to be summarized
by a first-order condition,
which is like a solution
to the subproblem.
Which subproblem?
This subproblem here.
So this is the branch where the
household as firm is borrowing.
And its payoff in curly brackets
is, in part, a function of z.
So if you differentiate
this function
with respect to
effort, you're going
to get the way that the
probability of success
is increasing with effort.
You're going to get a part
with a negative sign reflecting
the utility of effort.
And this probability of success
is also entering into this--
It's like the winner's curse.
You win.
Your profits are successful.
But you've got to
pay off the bank.
So the harder you work,
the more you repay.
So take the derivative of this.
And you get this
first-order condition
over here, equation seven.
So that's the formality of it
that it captures the notion,
as I've said, that no matter
what contract the firm is
entering into, the bank cannot
see the borrower's effort
but knows how the borrower
is determining it.
So we get this equation
7 as another constraint
on the program, if we believe
moral hazard is strained.
So we did limited liability.
We did moral hazard.
We could have both.
And now I'll show you
a very cool picture.
So this is utility of
a household as a firm.
But on the x and y-axis are
the inputs, the capital level
and the effort level.
If we did what we
would call first best,
meaning that we ignore
all the limited liability
and moral hazard
constraints, then
the borrower would maximize
these choices of capital
in effort, choose then
to have maximal utility.
And where is the
utility maximal utility?
It's in this bull's
eye over here.
So in other lectures,
we've talked
about bliss points, meaning,
if you're below bliss,
utility is increasing.
Or you could go
above bliss, which
is kind of weird, in which
case you want to dump stuff.
This is an endogenous
bliss point.
This came from solving
an underlying problem.
But we can, nevertheless,
plot the solution this way.
And where do they want to be?
As close to the bull's eye
as possible but not northeast
of it.
OK, so now what are the
constraints on the problem?
There's this
liability constraint,
which is capital times lambda.
And if that's the constraint
in the world and hence,
in the program, it
just simply says,
capital cannot be
to the right of it.
It can be to the
left of it or on it.
So all these solutions on
the vertical line and left
of the vertical line
correspond to satisfying this
capitalisation constraint
for a given value of lambda,
which is listed down here
at the bottom of the slide.
And where is the
maximal solution?
At the tangency right here.
That's where the slope of these
concentric rings goes vertical.
OK, let's do the moral hazard.
So ignore limited
liability constraint
and trace out this guy.
I did not a priori
what this constraint
was going to look like.
But if you plot it in the space
of k and z, it looks like this.
It's like this parabola.
Alex was my student and
RA for this project.
And Anna and I, former student,
were writing this paper.
We shared the problem with Alex.
And Alex came up
with this graph.
And Alex became a coauthor
of the paper and subsequence
collaborator in many things.
Anyway, I love this graph.
So if you want to satisfy
the moral hazard constraint,
you're going to be
on the parabola.
And where is the maximal point?
It's again, a tangency
with a concentric circle.
And it's right here.
So interestingly, if you
compare these two points,
the limited-liability
constrained solution
and the moral hazard
constrained solution,
limited liability involves
less capital and more effort
relative to the moral hazard
solution which kind of makes
sense because with moral hazard,
the problem is inducing effort,
not capital.
With limited
liability, the problem
is financing that
level of capital.
and effort's fully observed.
Now it turns out, if you
have both constraints,
in this world with
risk neutrality,
there's nothing to optimize.
It's like two lines cross.
Actually, technically,
it's a vertical line
crossing with a parabola.
But it completely nails
down the solution.
So k and z are at the
crossing over here.
So what we're doing
conceptually then
is loading in these
parameter values
for, in this case, a particular
talent level, particular asset
level, alpha in the
production function,
kappa, which is the
disutility of effort.
And the power is
lambda lambda, 1 is 0,
et cetera, solving the
model and delineating
what happens with these
various constraints, one,
the other, or both.
OK, so now we're going
to generalize this.
And in particular, we're going
to let there be some risk.
There is already risk.
But we're going to let the
household be risk-averse.
So their payoff can depend on
q, which they now care about.
The dispersion, because
they're risk-averse,
so there's a consumption,
this profit-sharing schedule.
And we're going to want to
solve for these probabilities.
This kind of came up in
the beginning of class,
this pi is a probability
number, an endogenous number
that reflects the solution
to a programming problem.
So we're going to
want to determine
the probability of seeing this
quadruple, a particular value
c, particular value of q, a
particular value of effort z,
and a particular
capitalization level, as
a function of observed and
unobserved characteristics
of the borrower, namely,
theta a and s, talent, assets,
and schooling.
So again, I don't remember
what slide it's on.
But we will determine
the solution
by these probabilities.
There are lotteries.
They will make our program and
turn it into a linear program.
And again, this is
a bit of a review,
but now in an interesting
applied context.
Remember, we had discrete
values for consumption
when we introduced
the notion of risk.
And we talked about
the probability pi,
of choosing a certain bundle,
discrete bundle, c, cs,
where s delineated all the
possible discrete values of c.
So that was one
place that we did it.
And there's been others.
But I don't have it right
off the top of my head.
Oh sorry, in the mechanism
design literature
in the previous
lecture we did it.
We had deterministic
programs and programs
with the lotteries.
So that's the second reason
to have the lotteries.
And I made the point there
that they were linear programs.
So despite putting in
truth-telling constraints,
when we have the
lotteries, the constraints
are linear in the pi and so
it was the objective function.
So here, we're going to have
these moral-hazard constraints,
et cetera, which could turn this
into a very nonlinear problem
because we have the
original maximum,
the objective function
subject to a derivative
of part of the maximized
function as a constraint.
And Lord knows what
that looks like.
But we turn it all into
a linear programming
problem with these lotteries.
Not only that, we're going
to imagine discrete values.
So it's not a
semi-infinite program.
It's a finite, discrete
linear program.
And that allows
capitalization to be chunky.
Maybe you get a machine or you
don't, for example, literally,
a discrete value.
That also causes a problem,
just the way chunky consumption
causes a problem.
But never mind.
Lotteries are the cure-all.
It just always works
to turn it into this.
So don't pass out.
Each of these lines
will make sense to you.
This is the objective function.
It's the utility of the
household as a function
of consumption and effort.
This is expected utility
because part of the probability
involves consumption and effort,
which may potentially be chosen
at random, according to pi.
And then we sum up over all
these discrete values of c, q,
z, k, summing them up,
weighting them by pi.
So this whole thing is
just expected utility.
In this case, the
borrower's risk-averse.
So we're allowing for that.
Now this constraint
is what I call
a Mother-Nature constraint.
What Mother Nature is giving
us is the technology that maps
z and k along with theta into
the probability of success, q.
So this p tilde
function is given.
It's part of the
underlying environment.
But you might think
that, in part, we're
solving for the relationship,
the probabilistic relationship
between q, z, and k because
everything looks endogenous up
here.
So we need to impose
another constraint
to make sure we respect
the Mother Nature.
And if little
statistics, this is
like the probability of
a conditioned on event
b times the
probability of event b
is therefore the probability
of the joint event a and b.
And on the left-hand
side, it's already
the joint event, a and b.
So this is the probability
of q, conditioned on z and k.
This is the
probability of z and k
because we've integrated out
the other objects, z and q.
So this is the
probability of q, z, k.
And likewise, the left-hand side
is the probability of q, z, k,
where we somehow integrate out
the only other object, the c.
So this is a
Mother-Nature constraint.
Again, it's all
linear in the pis.
So we just code it in to Matlab.
This thing down here is
the break-even constrain
for the bank.
And you can think of
it as maybe the bank
has to pay out more in
consumption than output.
In this case, by the way, when
the firm is not successful,
the output is 0.
But the borrower is
risk-averse and it's
going to view it as a disaster
to get 0 consumption, maybe
even minus infinity utility.
So typically, in
the failure branch,
consumption is greater than q.
That means the bank, which
is like taking all of the q
and giving some of
it back in terms
of c is suffering a loss
on the consumption part.
On the other hand, on
the right-hand side,
it's like the
firm, the household
as a firm is surrendering all
of its assets a to the bank
to manage.
And only some of it
gets used to finance.
So the firms make a profit
on the right-hand side,
times the difference
the bank got
that it didn't give back, times
the external outside interest
rate.
So this is a zero break-even
constraint with the lotteries.
This is moral hazard.
It's akin to truth-telling.
So what this says
is, the truth is
that not only does the borrower
characterize by theta a and s.
The borrower contemplates
doing the recommended action z.
How much effort is supposed to
be applied under the contract?
But you can't make
the borrower do it.
The borrower has to be given
incentive to work, especially
if this is a high level of z.
But the borrower says,
nah, I might not do it.
So even though z was
recommended by the bank,
the borrower does
something else.
The borrower does z prime.
Note that z prime is entering
into the utility function here.
So he really is going to do that
or is thinking about doing it.
And this would be the
utility consequence.
This stupid thing here, we have
to readjust the probabilities
because when we impose that
Mother-Nature constraint,
we embedded the
probability of success
into the endogenous object.
We would now be making
an error if we did not
adjust for the fact that
the effort being taken
is z prime rather than z.
And this is derived
in one of my papers.
Hopefully, it's somewhat
intuitive that at least one
needs to do an adjustment.
And finally, this just says the
probabilities all add up to 1.
So the programming
problem is to maximize
the expected utility
of the borrower,
subject to all
these constraints,
Mother-Nature constraints.
There's a lot of them.
For every q, z, and k, this
is the break-even constraint.
There's only one of them.
This is the
moral-hazard constraint
to be obedient
rather than shirk.
And there's one of
these for every k.
That could be assigned
and then for every z,
an alternative value z prime.
And there's only one of
these constraints 11.
So I'm actually enumerating
the set of all constraints.
You can solve these things
for a large number of control
variables pi, like thousands.
And you can have
hundreds of constraints.
And it's still solvable
in things like CPLEX,
which is a version
of which Gorubi
is publicly available software.
So we did this before
Gorubi was on the market.
So we paid $2,000 to
get a hold of CPLEX.
And we solved the linear
programming problem.
I'm going to call the
solution the probability
of being an entrepreneur.
It's a pretty brute
force, namely,
what is the probability the
capital level is positive?
If it's positive, they
must be a firm, the way
we composed the problem.
If capital were 0,
they're a wage earner.
So ignoring everything
else by summing up
over everything else, we
only care about capital
being positive.
And we call that the
probability of being a firm.
It's still conditioned on
talent, assets, and schooling.
So we have to solve this problem
for all those stratifications
in the data.
So let me go back again.
Is it a moral-hazard problem?
Is it a limited-liability
problem?
Is it both?
Is it neither?
So we have the master program
here that allows everything.
All we have to do is comment
out the relevant constraint.
If we want to look at the--
It should have
been written here.
If we want to delete the
moral-hazard constraint,
we comment out this
thing, equation 10.
And there's a limited-liability
constraint, which somehow I'm
not seeing in the notation.
But it should have been there.
And we can comment it out.
We can allow both moral
hazard and limited liability.
Or we could have neither.
Once you go to all the
trouble to code this thing up,
it's not hard to do all
these different combinations
and take it to the data.
So how do we go to the data?
We compute.
So again, I'm not being shy
about this because we advertise
that numerical methods are
important at the beginning
of the class.
So I do want occasionally
to show you how
numerical methods can get used.
And also, I know you
guys are a great class.
So I'm not worried that this
is necessarily too hard.
But it may be the first
time that you've seen it,
which is kind of
cool because you'll
learn about maximum likelihood.
So what do we do?
Let's fix all the parameters,
alpha, kappa, all of them,
a whole array of them--
I have that on
the slide coming--
and solve that
programming problem
for the stratification of
ability, education, and wealth.
And say, do that for
the moral-hazard regime.
Let's keep moral
hazard in mind now.
Drop limited liability.
Now we want to construct the
likelihood function, which
is for given parameter
values, the model
predicts the probability of
being a firm for households
of this type.
The model tells us that.
And in the data,
we see the number,
the fraction of the sample
that are firms in that wealth,
talent, schooling, category.
So there may be a bit of
a mismatch in the sense
that for given parameter
values, the probability
is low in the model and very
high on the data or vice versa.
So then logically, oh
well, we can play around
with the parameter values.
We don't know what
they are either.
So we vary, kappa and alpha
and all of those things,
to make the likelihood to
maximize the probability
that we would see in the data
what is predicted by the model.
Maximize the
probability, we would see
in the data, which is a given.
But it's predicted by the model.
And again, the choice is varying
over all possible parameter
values.
Now that doesn't mean the
likelihood will match exactly.
It just means the
likelihood is as high
as it can possibly be after
searching over all parameter
values.
Here's a bit more
of the math of it.
The string of
parameter values would
be risk aversion, work aversion,
the weight on disutility
in the work part, alpha in
the production function,
delta 0, 1, 2, which are the
weights on theta A, theta
and S, I think, or the
other way around, lambda
being the limited-liability
constraint.
So we're going to maximize
over all these parameters
and get something like H of A
to be the probability of being
a firm, conditioned
on wealth A. And it
should have had schooling
in here but not talent.
We had to integrate
out over talent.
So this object comes from
the model conditioning
on the stratification
in the data
and a string of
parameter values.
So when we say maximize the
likelihood, L, likelihood,
is a function of the
parameter values, which
we will vary, to maximize what?
Ei is a statement
about the data.
It's 0 or 1.
Household i is either a firm
or it isn't in the data.
So we count up the number.
Every time a household
is in the data as a firm,
we look at the associated
probability of predicting that
from the model.
This is a probability, likewise,
logs make it the same function.
It's just a monotone
function of the probability.
And logs are cool
because they allow
you to write everything
is separable instead
of multiplicative.
Here's the other event, a
given household in the data
is not a firm.
It's a wage earner.
So one minus 0 is 1.
So this branch is wage earner.
And what's the probability
of being a wage earner?
It's 1 minus the
probability of being a firm.
So this is the likelihood
function, the log likelihood
function, a function
of the parameters.
And this is where the
code is maximized.
This is not linear code.
This is nonlinear
optimization code.
But there are many routines
out there to do this.
And if you don't want to think
about maximizing its nonlinear
function, you can
just evaluate it
at thousands of these
parameter configurations
and pick the max, which actually
gets close to the maximum.
So too tiny to read,
but conceptually,
we have a moral hazard column,
a limited liability column,
and both constraints column.
And what we're doing with
various specifications,
including this one,
estimating talent,
is reporting the maximized
parameter values.
So again, that vector string was
gamma 1, gamma 2, kappa, and so
on.
And you can see the
point estimates.
For risk aversion,
which was gamma 1,
we're getting the point
estimates here of 0.06 or 0.02.
So almost risk
neutral, actually.
But in parentheses
is a standard error,
which is expressed a
degree of confidence
about the point estimates.
So those are the
parameter estimates.
So what do we find?
We find at the end of the day,
a couple of years of research,
that the central region
favors moral hazard.
And likewise, in
the cross section,
as we increased the wealth going
from one household to the next,
an increase in
wealth is associated
with an increase in net
saving, which we also measured.
So this is consistent with
moral hazard in the slide
I showed you at the beginning.
That if it's moral hazard
and you have higher wealth,
you avoid the damage caused
by the moral hazard constraint
by self-financing.
So you should be saving
more as wealth goes up.
In the Northeast, the
story is different.
Being constrained, like
below the constraint
or at the constraint,
is not related
to borrowing particularly.
Now it is true that if you were
at a constraint, the liability
constraint, and
wealth went up, then
they'd all be constrained
by definition.
But there's a branch
of entrepreneurs,
depending on talent,
like if talent is low,
their wealth is
more than adequate.
So they may not be
borrowing at all.
And likewise here,
we get the opposite
that when wealth goes up for
constrained entrepreneurs,
borrowing goes up.
But again, there's this
branch of entrepreneurs that
are not necessarily borrowing.
So that wording on that
bottom bullet point
is a bit difficult.
So we have succeeded
to solve the problem.
We've identified the constraints
that limit small businesses.
Interestingly, the
constraints are
different in the different
regions, in the industrialized
area near Bangkok,
which are very urban--
one of these villages is across
the road from a Ford Motor
Company plant, for example--
it looks like moral
hazard's the problem.
Out in the Northeast,
the problem,
which is agrarian,
mostly rural, the problem
seems to be there's a very
limited financing constraint,
limited liability.
And a lot of the households
don't have a lot of wealth
so they're either constrained or
don't go into business at all.
Now we're not doing
a policy thing here.
But it would be good for
policymakers to know this
because if they want to
alleviate the constraints
on small businesses, they
should direct their policy
toward maybe in the Northeast,
allowing more assets
to qualify as
collateral, not just land
but their motorcycles,
which they finally did,
and other things, putting it
in escrow to allow or to have
the bank to have a
claim on it and allow
to increase borrowing.
In the central, area it's
an information problem.
So there, if you're
determined to try to solve it,
it must be better monitoring.
You need better signals
of the underlying effort
by, well, let's try
costly state verification,
for example, which is something
I talked about last time.
Not with respect to
verifying output.
But with respect to
getting reliable signals
of the underlying
effort of the borrower.
OK so this is the economic
science part of it.
We have models.
We have data.
We're trying to get as close
to the data as possible.
We're also solving an
interesting financing,
getting understanding of
the financing constraint.
And thinking about how
policy would change,
depending on what we find out
rather than one size fits all.
So that's all I have for today.
OK, thank you very much.